hello everyone welcome back to the game
spot III 27 C 2017 stage it's a good job
joining myself and Timaeus Daniel or
Ella from Nintendo treehouse Lord and
Master of the trio no I don't a that
don't be horrible tell to have I here
bringing us Metroid's time mr. touch yes
merrily announced yesterday why sure for
you guys yes look Metroid funds as well
it was the years of complaining about no
Metroid you came out with two of them to
its yeah hey you guys stop complaining
we're doing it we've got an old one and
a new one so yeah so this is a remake
yeah this is a remake of the original
Game Boy game um but a lot of bells and
whistles been added to it they'd added a
bunch of new audio they added a really
strong 3d element to that gives it a
nice good vibrant feel too is you're
going through the game as well and some
new new abilities for same as to
advocate Arsenal as well so interesting
choice to go to this game of all of them
like obviously they are a well for 2d
Metroid games that you could have to
chose to reimagine in some ways some
people would have been like Super
Metroid one of the grace I think
greatest game of all time why why not
that what was it about Metroid 2 and
return of Samus that you desire uh it's
a good about the Dead that mean they've
there's so many different games to look
at me this is one they particularly so I
mean such an older game on the Gameboy
like super metrid bring already had
color going to a Game Boy given really
this is it feels completely new we take
the original Gameboy now go to this kind
of level of detail right I'm in two
different moves and new additions so
it's probably why the dev shows that
direction but it's better question ask
them directly yeah sure they had plenty
of really thoughtfully debated many
different option this is why they went
this one for maple ways and you and you
went with mercury steam and yes you
closer though you guys you guys tend to
keep Metroid Development well I was
going to say you tend to keep it
in-house but like you have experiment
we're going outside with you know other
em and that kind of stuff so what was it
about mercury Steam do you think that
attracted Nintendo to them they're just
a party they wanted to work with this
time around I mean there's they've had
they've done something the past before
so there's an opportunity to do
something different creative with them
we like pardoning them too yeah we
definitely work with work closely with
developers that best ones using one of
the Nintendo IPS especially when it's
cherish the sandwich so no I mean it's
just an opportunity and take advantage
of and they've done a great job with it
so far I mean I
to play a little bit myself and it just
it feels great playing on 3d and seeing
this right now you can't see the 3d here
now but even the trailer itself you
actually you can download a Nintendo
eShop and you actually could stock in 3d
right Tom which really helps this I know
we're only in 2d right now yeah but it
gives you get a whole different vibrant
life time yeah good as well tell us some
of the you briefly touched on a bunch of
them but can we go a little bit in
deeper into what the new abilities am
sure ya know a lot of things they added
to it um
I know a lot people might have played
the game rigidly and didn't really
realize there's some things like aiming
is a big thing this one too now like Sam
has the ability to aim in 360 degrees
right there you can see that Sarah is
playing for us by the way too but yeah
she's doing this whole 360 motion you
guys can even shows a targeting
targeting asset behind it and even
lights up red when you're actually
hitting that enemy oh nice
well here's a cool new move you're
showing too is the the melee counter as
well that Sam is can now do when enemy
comes flying at her she able to kind of
basically counter back if your being
able to shoot right away you can get a
critical hit out of it all right he
kills the enemy almost instantly by
doing that so there's a lot of cool foam
like that as well so oh sorry I was
gonna say that presumably those those
kind of like these new abilities they
they can update the game but it also
kind of introduces challenging because
you know the Metroid has a very specific
way of providing challenges the
limitations are almost a challenge to
yes always yeah but if you're able to do
things like you know aim everywhere does
that has a resulted in having a knock-on
effect in how how much of the game you
have to redesign because presumably you
know you're going to a certain room in
the old game you could only fire forward
or whatever it was now they're moving
everywhere now they're moving all
direction yeah the develop me the dev
team took that into account for sure
when they remade this games that they
wanted they wanted to add a challenge
who are familiar with the game already
but the same time they still want to
make it accessible people who've never
played a Metroid game shows maybe
people's first Metroid game especially
for younger kids right who would have no
idea what these games oh and the
challenge behind it as well so they want
to add some other some additional
abilities like that like the melee
counter and the 360 gaming which adds a
lot to and just the visuals with some
other abilities in a little bit too that
you had Samus has as well beyond what
she normally has like right now and
that's also also bring up to the
limitations is that's what's Samus is
known for that she's she's basically all
by herself on this planet um and she
bases that she's a Tessa very what's
going on and her arsenal is always
limited yeah just to build up her
arsenal and she goes from there as well
in terms of adding new
abilities um I guess how I have mercury
steams would have worked with Nintendo
to sort of make sure that it's an
authentic thing that Thomas would have
you know I mean ya know I mean that's
what they worked on when going through
the whole design of the game figuring
how to play and how that and how those
new abilities can add to gameplay
elements like the edge of Southie like
the melee counter we'll get to some
other abilities called the Aeon
abilities as well we're gonna show off a
little bit - which adds something
different to the game as well it just
gives it helps for different parts that
they can all be for different portions
like the melee attack being more
defensive and how to fight different
enemies the Aeon of bills and get to
that - is more of a scanning ability
like scan polls we'll get to that um
kind of changes up in that direction as
well okay cool
so you've redesigned samisen quite some
significant ways both got the world
around Samus is that similar to the
original version of the game it is some
others but I mean again it that was all
in just the old-school gameboy screen of
no color at all so I mean just bring all
that stuff to life is just something
different that people yeah got a chance
to experience when the dev teams were
working when the dev team was working on
this game - all together so people who
have a considerable amount of experience
playing the original version of game
perhaps may even know it off by heart
and they'll have a different kind of
experience here yeah for sure no I mean
they definitely wonder they want to make
sure people who came back to the game
experience a little bit different
challenge the new bosses which we kind
of showed a little bit in the trailer
right and those kind of things like that
wouldn't get a chance to fight one of
the bosses soon here as well right I'm
so it'll be fun in that aspect but ya
know that's what they're having a lot of
fun doing all these different things and
finally aspects of discovery and just
kind of having to explore the world in a
different way that you've never been
that's the thing that I guess I said
like Samus all by herself here just out
of fear I was going on and trying to
destroy the Metroid's okay which looks
like such cute little cuddly characters
but they're not deadly as yeah are you
gonna yes
step in there like yes be careful those
Metroid's okay except for that one baby
Metroid of course the baby vetrix yeah
but this is the new ability right here
that uh we're out to get right now is
what the Aeon ability um so this is
gonna add an element to the exploration
at UH so right now it's straight ahead
you don't know where you need to go like
my shooting straight ahead on the wall
we'll look at the test a second but yeah
when you start shooting the the area
right in front of you on will destroy to
your turret what where do I need to go
so there's a little yellow meter that
pierre there that's the basically the
energy of the Aeon abilities um there's
still subtle you bill to get but that
energy bar you those little yellow
spheres you got from defeating any
people keep refilling that so now you
can just scan polls and now you can look
at you actually need to go next keep
exploring on interesting that's that's
quite a significant change yeah a lot of
a lot of metroid is about hitting a wall
i think that's how you learn the world
right yeah kind of you hear you you hit
a dead end and you're like well i guess
they need to re-examine everything that
comes before whereas if you have this
ability now it's kind of like you always
know where to go so that must have been
an extent yeah question yes i mean
that's that's insane you want to make
the game accessible not just the
hardcore fans that people are never
played it and it's an ability you can
choose the user to choose not to use it
it's like the player to decide how they
want to use these things
okay take advantage of them maybe have
the map at the lower screen to which you
can even you can even put markers on the
map below to number location you haven't
gone to before so it's not like having
to memorize or draw like a Newark I was
a kid I've ever drawing maps I loved it
as you can write what you need to go
doing all those things as well this is
kind of drag and drop menu screen here
you simply just add where you want to
put locations right and remember where
you wanted to go because that's why I
don't that's one thing you learn from
Sam is from these games to is that when
you get these ability to go you have to
go back in track when you have to get
the morph ball to charge being things
like that yeah revolves well so this is
a fun thing to keep going in that
direction it seems that it seems like
small additions to it but as a long time
fun it's just it'll take me a little
time to get bored with exam like so used
to having this specific type of
experience with Metroid so this is kind
of like I welcome it yeah yeah it's
gonna take some time for me to get you
sit this is what I tell you never know
yes that's the mess Ryan but it's like
it's the addition to kind of make it
bring it to the modern day right because
the way they play the way the game is
played games mmm
has changed a lot yes and it's nice that
the game is sort of being updated to
affect that but you can also choose to
play it build what you want yeah that's
something to you mean the gaming has
just grown so much over the years I
remember when I was a kid I mean there's
only three people who play video games
and now they're trying to get people who
are like the hardcore gamers the more
casual gamers everyone has different
feels to it some people like playing for
20 minutes of you'll play 40 hour
sessions and huh right so
whatever works for each person going
through all that so yeah it's a fun
experience and that way to keep having
fun with the game yeah and I guess it
helps kind of build samus's profile back
up again she's been gone for quite a
while I like having the least amount
barriers to people enjoying Samus and
Metroid again would be beneficial for
future Metroid projects I imagine you
want you want to have people know the
character be kind of like engaged with
it and if you have an incredibly
difficult alterable Metroid game that
might be a bit difficult to do know for
sure and that's one who maybe like to
you can talk about the design like Samus
and this one looks a lot more like the
old-school manner look more like you see
in Smash Brothers yeah then what you see
in Metroid Prime which is cool and even
the amiibo reflects it as well there are
two new amiibo coming with yeah I wanted
samisen heard more classic like on her
on her yeah it's the cover isn't it yeah
the cover art yeah yeah it's really cool
but then even the other amiibo is the
Metro Metro it's even squishy yes all
right
Ritchie and a lot of people been
checking out in the booth I I don't buy
a lot of amiibo cuz I know if I did it
will become a problem buying I'm buying
that one for sure
no we had a moment when we were watching
the treehouse yesterday no everyone was
like amiibo oh god every one of you and
we just sort of felt like well let's get
up yeah
mightor preordered coming up I don't
send it for you right now oh and
actually here we're fighting against the
boss yeah yeah on this one of the first
enemy of the first kind of boss is gonna
fight yet to figure out how to defeat it
oh well now we know yeah thanks yes boy
this guy's in stairs actually really
good at this so she's yeah she basically
quickly did the melee count I went right
to her missiles ROM which'll time to go
down the are BA the shoulder button on
the side you able to then quickly see
that um yeah yeah it's very sort of like
obviously one of the big new Mechanics
for Metroid since Prime's introduction
has been scanning and kind of looking in
your environment and sure is there any
sort of element of that or was there a
discussion about maybe bringing that
forward I mean that's the scan pulse
carry does give it a bit of that aspect
there in the map at the lower screen
o'clock all on bad but ya know you mean
like skinning a claw energy and getting
behind it love to stay tuned and see
what they add okay like for nasty um I
know a lot people always that people
always want to know what is the story
how exactly do they tie together in some
how did all this all the Metroid games
tie together in some story this is
samus's grand in
you're told in many different ways so
it's really great to see how that plays
out and now he's got the charge beam I
also so yeah that's a thing too is you
can quickly see the Arsenal starting to
build all that via further in the game
which is really fun for just people to
experience yeah but it's like you're
hitting them like very quickly yet build
very quickly in like master them is it
is it gonna be like easy to play
difficult to master kind of or is it
gonna be looking fairly balanced it's
probably fairly balanced to me to having
the game stopped it's not released yet
I'll be coming out in September on the
15th but yeah well as we've Pete
everyone and that's up to every player
to at the same time it's you're saying
some players are gonna take this and
find that they're gonna be speedruns of
the whole thing that's their kind of
their their skillset some people I'm
more of a completionist where I'm gonna
want to find every little look and
created on the map and see what else I
can discover beyond that even try to
find all the secrets all the energy
tanks yeah all the missile all the
missile inventory increases all those
things as well I'm a big fan of the
aiming animation when she's aiming
behind us you just look forward right
like I I am too good for this the cool
thing see when you are aiming to if you
notice that when you're aiming at
enemies it actually turns red right yeah
get on that so you actually know when
you're going to hit okay so when you're
in line yes when your lattices that was
yeah that was tricky with the games
where you could aim diagonally yeah and
then lining it up and then shuffling
forward a bit just to him and enemies
were moving at the same time say
constantly going back and forth yes
but man this is we're ending our little
demo here now right that's properly to
be showing this animation here going on
but this thing right here that water
below is now dropping level before that
drop you couldn't go past anywhere
because it's that that water would just
basically kick damage right why you win
that's okay so when is this game coming
out September 15th time of 15 not need
me bow to us so you give up your turn
it's not far off no excited for that
well don't you thank you so much for
joining us and guys for all the latest
from e3 2017
don't go anywhere the lobby is gonna be
live from the e3 show floor in 15 or so
minutes we're gonna have Harvey Smith
talking about the new Dishonored DLC and
Jake Solomon talking about XCOM so make
sure you stay tuned